this probably looks like a bunch of tiny
individual orange worms Tangled together
but it is in fact a worm belonging to
the genus serratulus that can get to
around 12 centimeters in length and
along with its distinctive color the
worm is easy to spot and wet Sandy mud
because of those threads you see waving
across your screen some of these threads
are tentacles but others are actually
gills and in the water those threads
seem to float serenely but this effect
is lost on land in a paper from the
beginning of the 20th century titled
notes on the Ecology of serratulus
tentaculatus the author wrote when
withdrawn from the mud seratalus
presents an exceeding limp and
bedraggled appearance
[Music]